dijiste que conocías a todos en la
escuela pero coincidiste con ellos en la
nueva y ahora te agradan ya conocí a
algunos de mis compañeros porque me
trasladé con ellos no lo sé es la ciudad
es muy sospechosa
a
reunimos a siete estudiantes de escuelas
privadas soy estudiante de una escuela
privada estudiantes de una escuela
previo y estudiante de una escuela
privada soy estudiante de una escuela
privada dos de ellos son estudiantes de
escuelas públicas si descubren quiénes
son los mentirosos se repartirán el
premio
si los impostores sobreviven ganarán
todo el premio quienes serán los
impostores 5 estudiantes de escuelas
privadas versus 2 de escuelas públicas
que clases ven ahora en la escuela estoy
cruzando cine geometría español salud y
bienestar historia inglés y física
conceptual historia moderna inglés
avanzado español avanzado religión ética
pública y moral e inglés historias
ciencias español avanzado también y arte
por adelantado
matemáticas hebreo historia arte
ciencias ya no se me ocurre más no podía
recordar bien las clases a las que
asistí a lo que me pareció un poco raro
ya llevas medio año en estas clases otra
cosa que no puedo quitarme de la cabeza
soy el único que llevó el vídeo de una
pregunta para ti cuál es tu uniforme en
un código de vestimenta no uniforme pero
solo se nos permite usar azul pastel o
azul claro gris azul marino y blanco y
blanco sólo los viernes si está
codificado por colores y solo me pongo
esto los jueves porque vamos a la
capilla y nuestro es un pantalón kaki
una chemise su uniforme no parecía único
de una escuela privada un viernes al mes
se nos permite llevar jeans lo que
hacemos los viernes usamos camisetas y
jeans contrariando nuestros grados hoy
en séptimo grado estoy en octavos pero
en primer año estoy en primera unidad o
grado se creó de la 7º grado
muy rápido muy rápido nuestros
seguidores votaron quién es el impostor
muchas de las clases que nombró eran
clases a las que mis amigos en la
escuela pública asisten
al menos en mi experiencia a las
escuelas privadas no tienen sexto grado
suelen ser de séptimo a doceavo muchos
de los chicos estamos usando colores
aburridos ella lleva una camiseta roja y
eso me llamó mucho la atención hay un
empate el empate es entre cali y otro
cada una tiene 20 segundos para exponer
su caso empezando por halle soy
estudiante de una escuela privada voy a
harvard westlife juego voleibol vendo
libros la temporada terminó formo parte
del club de videojuegos de la ufc y el
club de lectura bien me llamo o tribuye
una escuela privada me gustan mucho las
innovaciones mi clase es muy pequeña
these niños incluyendo miami yo juego
fútbol en la escuela me gusta el
laboratorio de ciencias y hacer
experimentos
[Música]
a
y bing estoy muy sorprendida de haber
perdido el desempate pensé que iba a ser
halle porque no damos una breve
descripción de cómo es nuestra escuela
será la primera es una escuela de tamaño
decente hay al menos 20 niños en nuestra
clase sino menos conoces a todo el mundo
allí también es una escuela secundaria
ellos se ofreció a hablar con mucha
prisa me hizo pensar que quería el grupo
de su lado hay dos campus el campus
inferior y superior ahora estoy en el
campus inferior en ambos campus hay 1500
personas y 15 personas en cada clase es
pero espera dices que hay 1500 personas
en cada clase no no no no en general
entre ambos
eso les ha ido a la escuela privada toda
mi vida pero mi escuela primaria era muy
pequeña todo el mundo se conocía los
profesores conocían a los alumnos
conocían a los padres ya toda mi familia
si pasaba algo por la mañana para el
almuerzo todo el mundo lo sabía me
gustaba mucho un chico y corrían rumores
por ahí estaba en quinto grado y
llamaron a mi madre para hablarles de
eso ella se enfadó mucho estoy en una
escuela que va desde jardín de infancia
hasta secundaria completa como les dije
estoy la secundaria pero nos gusta
mantenernos alejados de los estudiantes
de último año son un poco abusivos
nuestros baños son vandalizados por
ellos así que tenemos carlos bailando a
la primaria y si exactamente quieren
hablar de la seguridad en la escuela se
sienten seguros cuando estaba en la
escuela pública nunca me sentí inseguro
en cuanto a daño físico pero sí en
cuanto al acoso verbal y ese tipo de
cosas soy gay no me había sentido seguro
de que con radio en la escuela pública
hay mucho acoso se burlan de ti se
burlaron de mí por ser gay en quinto
grado antes de que supiera que era gay
soy de la zona de la bahía así que es
una escuela más progresista es un
programa de educación para superdotados
cuatro clases al día y los viernes es un
día de proyectos hacemos un poco de
trabajo comunitario porque así son estas
escuelas en mi escuela está en arizona
son tres edificios una cafetería un
gimnasio un edificio para secundaria y
al lado está el edificio para el resto
de los grados estoy cursando inglés
avanzado ciencias estudios sociales y
álgebra y mis dos selectivas una
educación física y teatro
y yo también
inglés avanzado estudios sociales son
clases muy muy típicas en la escuela
pública en especial pienso eso que es lo
mejor de tu escuela privada yo hablaré
primero porque estuve en una escuela
pública desde el jardín de infancia con
un grado y luego me trasladé a la
escuela episcopal de santa margarida el
cambio es mucho mejor increíble en las
escuelas públicas el queso se cae de la
pizza asistí a la escuela pública
durante el preescolar y la única cosa
que recuerdo es que la comida era gratis
esto es genial pero ahora tengo que
pagar por ello todo el tiempo vale la
pena pero me si hay algo que no
comprendo antes dijiste que has asistido
a escuelas privadas todo durante el
preescolar no cuento eso sabes todo lo
que sé es que la comida era gratis pero
no me gustaba mucho esa escuela también
tenía secundaria pero me trasladé en
octavo grado a otra escuela secundaria
conocía a todos fui a una nueva escuela
privada y ahora me agradan más dijiste
que conocías a todos en la escuela pero
coincidiste con ellos en la nueva y
ahora te agradan ya conocí a algunos de
mis compañeros porque me trasladé con
ellos no puede ser
de nuevo quiero escucharla
ha cambiado durante el preescolar fui a
la primaria de la calle 6 en el jardín
de infantes me transfería otra escuela
no voy a nombrarla porque no quiero que
se enojen estuve allí durante nueve años
mi hermano fue a la misma secundaria y
para ella fue estupenda le dije a mis
padres que quería estudiar en esa
secundaria y ahora estoy ahí toda mi
familia nos encanta y eso es todo
ojalá me gustará mi escuela
no podía mantener su historia en orden
estaba nerviosa y en general era
sospechosa
[Música]
a
vaya adiós adiós no creo que me puse muy
a la defensiva empecé a entrar en pánico
hablar rápido y eso no me ayudó levanten
la mano si creen que los impostores
continúan con ustedes y si les gustaría
seguir el juego
tengo algunas sospechas de ti
este es un uniforme escolar no no
tenemos uniforme escolar tenemos un
código del sonido poco lo cuál es tu
código de vestimenta no sé cómo
describirlo solo recibe a la punta de
los dedos no pueden verse las tiras del
brasier el cuerpo debe estar cubierto
tengo una pregunta dijiste que la
educación física era colectiva para mí
es obligatoria sí porque yo tengo
educación física como incidir educación
física es un electiva pero es una
electiva obligatoria es de esa que debes
cuidar
igual es obligatoria tienes que elegir
entre artes escénicas de mozart o tienes
que elegir educación física yo elegí
educación física todos tienen un credo
para su escuela un guión un credo como
nunca lo he oído un creo escolar como
estamos comprometidos con la honestidad
la justicia y el aprendizaje respetamos
la dignidad y el valor de todos los
seres humanos
no es gruesa aprender haciendo aprender
cuidando el nuestro es en cool y somos
amables confiables y honestos nos
guiamos por versículos de la biblia como
juan 3 16 somos una escuela
vamos a oído a rezar a la capilla si en
harvard weasley hay escritas muchas
cosas cosas que se supone que debes
hacer algo así como re podrías hablarnos
más de tu escuela porque se
necesita ser un poco más claro si bien
fui a una escuela primaria pública y
luego me cambié en séptimo grado así que
va a ser sexto grado así eso que lo dije
eso bien el último grado me cambié
tenemos dos campus está el campo
superior y el inferior hay unos 1500
personas en cada uno en todo el campus
no en cada uno así que en cada clase hay
una con dos y seis clases el grupo
completo se cambia de la clase de
historia del mundo a matemáticas a
ciencias es algo así sí así entonces hay
muchos salones en verdad el campus de
siguen en las asambleas en nuestra
escuela veía vídeos y cosas en youtube
porque publican todo en youtube para los
complicó y se las hacían antes del
convite eran una vez al mes una vez al
mes me estoy debatiendo entre ustedes
todos chicos
sobre la forma en que escribiste tu
escuela el nombre de la escuela las una
vez al mes poner todo en youtube
ese es el mismo cronograma de las
asambleas que tuve en las escuelas
públicas que que es algo único en tu
escuela ya lo en la diferencia de una
escuela pública normal ya lo dije antes
tienes que elegir lo que quieres hacer
como elegir entre educación física o
artes escénicas entre las selectivas
obligatorias
[Música]
ah
adiós
no te echaré de menos por que votarían
por mí pensé que había logrado que
confiaran en mí realmente me sorprendió
mucho porque todo lo que escuché de ton
lo hago en mi escuela levanten la mano
si creen que los impostores continúan
con ustedes y si quieren seguir el juego
pensaba que habíamos sacado los
impostores android tone no quería
continuar cali siento mucho decir esto
pero gracias a dios olivia quería que el
juego continuara porque no me siento
seguro de terminar el juego ahora es
cuando vamos a seguir solo quiero
preguntar que encuentras que es único en
tu escuela algo que no hayas dicho como
las clases son pequeñas podemos hablar
más con los profesores eso era malo los
profesores por sus nombres con algunos
de ellos depende de la relación la gente
se comporta mejor que las escuelas
públicas siento que entiendo las clases
mucho si yo pero la educación en general
es mejor que la que encontraste en una
escuela pública bueno en primer lugar me
encuentro más animada porque es más
interesante lo que me enseñan y lo que
hacemos en una escuela pública es sólo
aprendemos sobre la historia de eeuu
pero aquí aprendemos sobre historia
romana estonia griega nos enseñan sobre
la historia del mundo pero además octavo
grado es el año en el que se aprende
sobre la historia del mundo es como la
escuela pública para mí es como estar
aprendiendo de nuevo todo el lamento
haber jugado la cuarta ronda después de
escuchar a jal y contar su historia
acerca de su escuela privada este es tu
uniforme del día
este no es mi uniforme de alguien me
gusta vestir formal me gusta usarlo pero
debo usarlo los jueves para ir a la
capilla porque supongo que es por
respeto y el resto de los días llevamos
un uniforme de color una chemise y un
pantalón en colores gris carmesí azul
marino o a cuadros eres específico si lo
dije todo tiene en su capilla si vamos
todos
pero vamos todos los miércoles y ambos
practican la religión si estudian bien
una escuela privada para superdotados
haces lo que quieres hacer sin
limitaciones mi escuela es bastante
diversa y si esa es la pregunta que iba
a hacer la diversidad como dirían hay
diversidad es un director de equidad e
inclusión tenemos lo que llaman bien el
equipo jed y justicia equidad diversidad
e inclusión yo dirijo la alianza de
género y sexualidad hay un club de
feminismo la unión de estudiantes negros
hay algún club al que te hayas unido
porque sé que ofrecen a los estudiantes
el club de su vida bien soy parte de la
unión y bien bien perdona pero cuál es
el
proceso de aplicación solo hicieron la
prueba si bien en mi caso también
dólares por la inscripción en su caso
cuánto fue haremos los costos 20 mil
tengo una beca así que si en mi caso 50
mil creo bien no puede ser
[Música]
ah
adiós halle adiós
levanten la mano si creen que los
impostores continúan con ustedes y si
quieren seguir el juego si las luces
cambian a verde significa que han
expulsado a los impostores sigan a las
luces rojas significa que el impostor
sigue en la caja y pierden
y
los eliminamos
que vienen trabajo y trabajo bien los
impostores den un paso adelante en 3 2 1
gracias pensé que va a salir en la
primera ronda cielos conozco esta
escuela y me decía no sé si es en el
informe se los dije lo sabía uno de tus
amigos bases y de todos mis locos para
el poder y la das por eso pero muy si no
son rara porque mi escuela va desde el
jardín de infancia hasta sexto grado
creo que lo hicieron muy bien me
sorprendió mucho que fueran los
impostores no me lo esperaba
entonces los cuales pública o privada
sólo comprado twitter no voy a una
escuela pública adopte la personalidad
de mi mejor amiga ella va a un escolar
pensar que todos somos ricos es un gran
error porque conozco a muchos
estudiantes que tienen ayuda financiera
becas académicas becas deportivas la
gente siempre piensa que los estudiantes
de colegios privados se comportan mal y
son descontrolados que no siguen normas
y son traviesos yo no creo que eso sea
cierto creo que son muy extrovertidos y
apasionados por lo que hacen siempre he
querido hacer esto y yo también
lluvia de dinero
[Aplausos]
pueden recoger todo todos los billetes
sí sí
muchos quizás si nos dijeran antes que
tendríamos que recogerlos nos llenaría